jallanges posé entre vignes et fleuve
loire un domaine construit au xvème
siècle par le roi louis 11 aujourd'hui
le château est devenu itinéraire
culturel du conseil de l'europe pour sa
promotion de saint martin de tours
représenté ici partageant selon la
légende son manteau avec un pauvre une
sculpture monumentale de 7 mètres
réalisé uniquement par des artistes
locaux avec des objets de récupération
les pèlerins lancés sur les chemins de
saint martin pourront s'y recueillir
c'est un symbole est tout à fait
particulière parce qu'elle est la
symbolique a tiré par louis 11 qui a
construit le château challenge qui avait
lui-même des affinités
pour saint martin pour l'histoire de
saint martin et qui a rendu le
pèlerinage saint martin sous son règne
le plus populaire au monde
l'heure est encore à l'installation de
l'oeuvre
planté au milieu du parc comme un
remerciement à celui qui fut le mécène
des pérégrinations du sein à travers
l'europe
des
fêtes
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui un chantier
international où quelques l'abord de
nombreuses personnes j'ai onze
collaborateurs j'ai une seule française
nous avons des bulgares polonais
gabonaise espagnoles italiennes pardon
italiennes anglaises
fidèle bras droit et anglaise oui c'est
très très européen il parle anglais tout
le temps et c'est intéressant
le saint martin partageant son manteau
sera inauguré vendredi soir dans les
jardins de jallanges le domaine se
visite tous les jours jusqu'à la fin du
mois d'octobre